herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
leute endlich kann ich dieses video
machen ich bin mega hype
wir werden auch erfahren warum es nun
aktuell bieten mache ich heute liebt wie
ich persönlich kenne also jetzt wie
einfach über auch keine dasein
verrechnung haben und der ziemlich
lustig sind wir machen das ganze
irgendwie ohne bildschirmaufnahme das
heißt sobald ich irgendwas zeige konnten
die rein und ich könnte auch sagen die
kinder sagen so vor langen reden
beginnen wir mit der ersten apple auch
gleich damit auf sich hat die erste app
folgt vom sparmodus ausschalten
die experten folgende einfach nur ein
lila mit logo und was hat es mit dieser
app aussieht
so ist eine geschichte die zwischen
wellen und wahrt kann diese nicht reife
als das wort verschickten und das klingt
erstmal natürlich unnützen erfahre wird
noch viel viel kraft
diese app wurde nämlich mit mehreren
millionen dollar unterstützt also die
syndrom gegangen haben gesagt ihnen die
räume eng machen video als leute
schicken kann
wir wollen geld dafür und die leute
haben mehrere millionen dollar ergeben
es ist so verrückt also einem
risikopuffer achim schick mantel hat nun
immer interpretiert kugeln hergerichtet
und so damit zum beispiel den ttl jemals
beispiels nicht überstanden ein nein und
der user name ist hahaha drei segmente
sandy jetzt hier ist das ctl nach ist
klasse die auf
zweiter fall nochmal auf jürgen und das
ist alles was diese bescheuerte macht
sondern für die neue nachricht man
klickt drauf und kann einfach klicken ja
objekt mehrere millionen dollar funding
also komplett behälter wieder nicht mehr
die nächste fdp ja es war für alle leute
von euch die eine katze haben und zwar
ist es ein mensch köpfe über rapper
diese exklusive haustyrann gesandt sein
wenn ihr auch zur verstört oder
aggressiv werden benutzen die wege
lieber dazu ihre freunde zu nerven die
sind auf jeden fall sehr feuchten ihre
eigenen app aber auch die mit der
werbung einfach angst wir können das
einsprechen jojo was du tust du sprichst
auch taktisch
was habe ich gerade gesagt ob menschen
spaß habe ich gesagt nein
doch jojo was geht hab ich gesagt jeder
der das hört soll klagte abonnieren
macht so direkt mal leutenecker man kann
hier noch unterschiedliche karten
man kann einfach nur geräusche machen
beim springen beim aufstehen
eigentlich wäre fehl am platze über die
funktioniert und dann machen wir weiter
nächsten das video im kasten oder warten
wir machen ich mein experiment big pack
is back und ihr spielt das video euren
katzen vor und schreibt die kommentare
ob sie darauf reagiert haben
ich hab dich lieb
schreiben sie kommentare leute die
nächste apple special
wieder hatte ich auch erst die idee
gekommen das video zu machen und zwar
wirklich eine serie von valley high
speed flächen personen in der disco und
in dieser serie geht es auch darum zu
entwickeln uns da zu begründen und so
und ein entwickler hat halt so gar
nichts drauf und hat seit ewigkeiten
eine entwickelt geht also dafür mal
wirklich vorstellen was die app macht
ist nicht anderes zu sagen ob man einen
hotdog häufig hat oder nicht
also quasi er hat auch noch alle zwei
jahre wird es im video auftreten können
und das war auch der grund weshalb
dieses wir so eine plane die etic geld
davonkommen aber ich brauchte um die app
herunterzuladen amerikanische apple
heute meine erstellen und dafür wiederum
auch nicht eine amerikanische
kreditkarte wird es dann irgendwie
geschäftsführung zu finden da anmelden
konnte dann die ab montag vorläufig kann
und was vielleicht da ich mache für euch
so wie ihr es aber wenn die halt auch
wirklich so ein ironisches produkt ist
gehen wir auch noch mal in den app store
und gucken uns anlass dazu steht für wen
ihr die beispielfotos potter bücher und
wir uns mal das video an
[Musik]
es ist der wahnsinn wenn man die
kommentare die rezensionen das remake in
gemanagt also dank dieser app glaube ich
wieder an die menschheit an das gute in
der mensch heißt best hot dog feine auf
der als sie hat anscheinend etwas drauf
die erster linie simply genie nicht
irrational also die leute loben die der
app in den höchsten tönen des hais
probleme sich auf die sind doch alles
andere in diesem zimmer ist kein hort
doch ich würde da in diesem bereich
auszutesten losgeht
da ist also wenn man sich einfach mal so
das interface an er ist einfach ist
einfach quatsch ineos würde man würde
der engländer sagen
probieren wir das ganze einfach kein
autor ist zum beispiel not geraten sind
ist der wahnsinn parat der wellpappe
weil doch eigentlich ist ein produkt der
marke cm finger ist meinte ja ein hotdog
oder mit mal die etwas genial der bürger
nachkommen können
das motto geprägt werden dürfte der
große moment ist da
jahrelange vorbereitung vor dem kaufhaus
in europa
foto oder experten solide vor der kamera
[Musik]
nächstes jahr wird ein finger bisschen
rein
wir gucken wir wie intelligentes der app
aller zeiten austricksen können habe ich
noch nicht runter geladen weil ich euch
zeigen wir dass ich dafür ein euro nur
um euch zu zeigen
es handelt sich dabei um einen fake oder
mit anderen worten um einen ventilator
was diese app macht ist sie spielt die
ein ventilator auf dem bildschirm acht
der kühlen wird für den sommer angaben
die rektoren verkaufen die apple klagen
für eine einzige mädchen für
geschüttelte menschheit jemals gekauft
wirkliche geschichte
ich habe früher mal vage gebraucht 11
bei eurosuper im app store nach einer
bank anvertrauen im technik geht einfach
so tief dass wir denken muss einfach hin
ich habe gerade für diese app hier eine
euro neuen bezahlt der kurzen weg und
wird noch bestimmt ein
standortübergreifendes für eine freund
so kann laufen wird oftmals ob das mit
mir kann eigentlich gar nicht
funktioniert
merkel ich will ist der winkel abgekühlt
man guckt mal zu samstag wenn überhaupt
nichts
oh mein gott ein ventilator und damit
auch letzte erste crazy die gibt es
aktuell in der originalform nicht mehr
im app store zu kaufen weil wir einfach
zu uns war
die einfach mal über höhere gehalt 5
greene shirt aus dem appstore von 2008
ppm bridge und wenn jemand hier unten
drauf schaut der preis liegt bei 1.000
dollar und jetzt fragt ihr euch bestimmt
was kann diese app 1000 dollar ist ja
keine ahnung was kann soll die
menschheit retten von irgendwas keine
ahnung oder krankheit mache ist in
dieser abfahrt wird lediglich ein foto
von einem rubin also im prinzip dieses
foto von einem rubin was auch auf dem
apple logo und der will von dieser etwa
dass leute sich die unterlagen können um
andere zu zeigen
heinrich ich bin noch ganz viele ableger
von leuten wie nachmachen wollen im app
store auch aktuell wenn jetzt mal ein
rich eingehen es ist mittlerweile
verboten einfach krone.at zu machen der
kreativ geworden
neben das gleiche foto von einem ritt
und machte gebühren komplett neues
minispiel reimann verkaufens für 110
euro und packen auch in app käufe reihen
also dass wahlkampf zu gehen aber ich
denke mir das wirklich interessant für
euch rand 5
gleich auf jeden fall für die nächste
video wir haben ein richtig geiles
geplant damit nicht verpackt können
jetzt abonnieren